Made in Chelsea star Spencer Matthews
has been caught up in a robbery at a
jewelry store in central London this
footage shows the moment the suspects
fled the scene on mopeds Matthews had
been at the back of the watch shop on
Duke Street in central London when it
happened
goodness the reality TV star told his
story on Instagram earlier and these
guys drive a scooter through through the
glass I start battering the shot like
with hammers big huge hammers wearing
helmets we're in the back of the shop
looking at them spring downstairs hide
in the vault until all the noise passes
let's speak now to the man himself
Spencer Matthews who is the owner of
Eden ROCs diamonds hello to you Spencer
it's good to talk to you I would have
thought being on hunted meant that you
knew how to hide yes absolutely thank
and thank you very much Kay for having
me on the show by the way the snaps new
career-high for me me too frankly
Spencer me too
tell us what happened I just popped in
to see the owner of official watches the
the our the our house is a friend of
mine Dena I just popped in to see him
briefly as I usually do if I'm in the
area and and they chaos ensued it was a
pretty scary bunch of guys on a moat on
mopeds with big sledgehammers came and
really gave the front of the story good
battering and yeah we had to take cover
in the safe downstairs which as you know
you may or may not know that's where
most of the goods are so no it was a
scary ordeal how long did it last for
it lasted for a few minutes
you know I were not not not saying that
anyone didn't kind of do their job we
try we called the police doubt from
downstairs wasn't much reception and
then no it kind of it kind of came and
went quite quickly quite scary though
men and helmets and a lot of noise
obviously to get through this kind of
glass requires an awful lot of force and
for someone who has a business that also
guards you know safe guards goods of a
similar nature our thoughts go out to
the staff must have been very scary
absolutely did they know that these guys
did that we can see them running it away
with their mopeds were chatting to you
did they know that you were there or
where they just so focused on the goods
that they were just grabbing what they
could and left god I hope they don't
know that I was there they may have
stated they may have stuck around they
may have come downstairs and tried to
rob me personally no there was I'm sure
they didn't see me actually we saw them
so we were in the back and we heard them
trying to get in and we kind of locked
ourselves in the back and then realize
that it's just a little wooden door so
we thought okay we might as well put
ourselves in the vault so we actually
had to come back into the main store
where they were to sneak through the
side door down to the vault but
fortunately they didn't follow us and
always well shortly after in fact the
only watch they didn't steal was the one
that I came to pick up just say what did
they take glorious
they took absolutely everything they
took everything from the floor you know
all windows broken everything and I'd
come in to pick up a piece actually and
it turns out that the only piece that
wasn't stolen was that piece and it was
on the floor under a big piece of glass
so a kind of upsetting morning turned to
a luckier one for just me yeah how you
feeling
I feel all right at the time it was kind
of exciting is the wrong word if you
know what I mean but I certainly didn't
need a coffee once I left